we have not really talked about covid
for a while because it's become kind of
background noise to so many people
whether that's right or wrong i'm not
saying but it has become background
noise to a large share of the united
states
but we're currently in the middle of a
wave so massive that the real number of
infections
might be 500 000
infections per day already already now
and you might say well but hold on a
second david those aren't the official
numbers right now and you would be
absolutely correct but i'll explain um
if you look at the official case numbers
you'll see that we're back up to about a
hundred thousand cases per day in fact
if i look at the absolute newest numbers
we're at about 99
500 cases per day so call it a hundred
thousand cases per day
but we're now at a point
where there's just a ton of sort of like
who cares around the country
and the belief is that we're capturing
maybe only one out of five actual
infections that we have now remember a
case is you've got a positive test an
infection is someone has the virus
whether it shows up as a positive test
or not and there's a few different
reasons that we are not capturing nearly
all of the infections number one
many people are just no longer getting
tested when they have symptoms oh i've
got symptoms yeah it's probably covid or
not i don't know but i'm just staying
home or maybe i'm not even staying home
if you're less responsible or unable to
um but that's an infection and it's not
showing up as a case that's that's first
and foremost number two
we have a ton of people getting home
tests and these home tests there's
nothing magical there's no
wi-fi bluetooth or rfid in your home
test if you test positive on a home test
and you don't report it anywhere that
also doesn't show up in the case numbers
even though it's an infection and then
thirdly there's essentially no more
testing of asymptomatic people going on
very sparingly there are places that are
doing surveillance testing uh meaning
everybody gets tested on some period of
time friends of mine and family who work
in academic settings some of them say
yeah we get tested once a week or twice
a week
um just to keep the campus sort of in a
regular testing mode but that's
basically gone away
and so asymptomatic people are
essentially not showing up anywhere and
so to get the real number of infections
we have to multiply by roughly five says
dr eric topple who has a great twitter
on covet stuff and he's been a guest on
the show meaning that our 100 000
official cases per day
probably means around half a million
actual infections per day which is just
an incredible number now the good news
so far is that if we look at deaths
deaths continue to decline
and we typically believe there's about a
three or four week delay from when cases
increase
before you see an increase in deaths and
it's been two months of increasing cases
and deaths continue to decline
now down uh
technically below the level of flu
deaths in the united states in the sense
that if in the average or i'm sorry no
that's completely wrong but i i
apologize that's not true at all
we average about a thousand flu death
i'm sorry a hundred flu deaths a day in
an average flu season
um and word about 250 kova deaths a day
so still two and a half times as many
covet deaths as flu deaths
but hospitalizations are going up so it
is very uh it's conceivable and
plausible that soon we are going to see
the death numbers go up as well we're
already seeing a 20 increase in
hospitalizations now in the meantime we
are learning many new things about covid
one of those is not a good piece of news
it's that covid is now uh evolving
quickly enough
with enough variants that are we've had
variants forever but now the variants
actually seem to slightly more regularly
out compete each other as dr eric topple
has written about and this means that
more quickly we are getting variants
that can break through boosters
and can break through natural immunity
as well to reinfect people potentially
multiple times per year that's very very
much
not good now there is one bit of good
news if we want to look for one which is
that we're currently in what's being
colloquially called wave five or also
known as the ba4 slash ba five wave
remember we had the original omicron
wave and then uh the secondary omega
okay so now we're on ba4 and ba5
variants if you look at south africa
you see that this wave five has already
leveled off and started to decline
and so
oftentimes what happens in south africa
happens in the united states somewhere
around you know six eight ten weeks uh
six to eight weeks later
um and we hope that that's the case and
that this is the peak but this is these
are incredible numbers half a million
infections believed per day
and one other element of this that's a
bit concerning is we may already be kind
of behind on vaccines the omicron
tailored vaccine
which is going to be tailored to the
first omicron variant back from uh
late november early december 2021
that vaccine is going to be out in a
couple of months and by then we're going
to be like five variants away so so from
that so there's a real question
as to whether we can even keep up or
catch up when it comes to vaccination uh
because um it takes a while to get the
vaccines updated so that's what's going
on i'd be curious to hear from you leave
a comment send an email send a tweet
at this point are you taking any coveted
precautions at all i know many people in
the audience are taking full precautions
and many people in the audience are
taking absolutely no precautions at this
point in time as of what i heard from
you guys about a couple months ago let
me know where you are right now
what if you could get through an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top non-fiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient
i just used blinkist to listen to the
book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get 25 off a premium subscription that's
just 6.25 a month the link is down below